[Música]
[Aplausos]
o pessoal se já ouviram e fanta morrer
não eu mostro o blog infante
[Aplausos]
o pessoal aqui quem fala e sejam muito
bem vindos
todas estaremos e sejam muito bem vindos
e é mais um vídeo fica preso quarta
mostrado já que um dos vídeos mais os
teores de sempre eu sei o clube opte
explicar o que é que eu vou gravar as
chamas homofonia e pra quem não sabe o
que é que eu vou explicar como o funil
basicamente você escutar em um sono em
3d mas tem por ser a mesma que a nossa
volta este é um elo afunila de rotulá é
muito muito medo porque eu já ouvi a
parte inicial portanto para o país que a
otan e os quintos o cumprimento uma
coisa só vamos fazer deste um choque
juntos num o que vocês vão ter que fazer
é colocar o vídeo em full screen eu sei
que vai ser algo em 2008 esquina mesmo k
coloque o volume no máximo isso sim é
importante mas sim os seus fones 3101
seus fãs da raiz e pode ser um fone
igual e na prova em oito anos você tem
que fazer aumentar o volume e os iphone
foi do vitória neto ao instrumento muito
medo mesmo preparem se preparem se
preocupar a a vamos lá vamos lá começar
o pessoal embora o a321 um negócio é
comer como você aumentar muito o nome do
mundo
[Música]
tudo já está resolvido
o objetivo é tentar não assustar pessoal
vamos tentar alguém chutar uma lata uma
coisa assim vou bater em qualquer coisa
entrou o vídeo eu sou vittek eo twitter
que está muito assustado já um homem um
homem entrou no quarto
partilhando vitor
esta foi a parte exatamente aqui foi
onde eu fui o vídeo quando houve a
primeira vez fui que ai vai fazer qual
eu fui fazer qualquer coisa mulher vai
para a costa utah arrebentar com do time
está com tudo
gostava que para nenhuma das aulas já
que elas também eu eu estou na volta ela
estacionar ok eu já não sei não sou
perfeito estado enfim ao pessoal vocês
já viram está muito real e até muito
perto de aumentar chegando ao fundo o
homem da equipa e estou aqui
o mensagem olha eu estou a andar a bater
o despertar da amiga
está louco tua mãe karen 2008
há muita confusão já não cabe colocar
dentro ainda um homem fugiu lá por fora
e elas estão cá dentro
ainda recorrer só isso é muito intensa
sério que aumente o volume fique comigo
há motivo para o vovô
elas serão unificadas dentro que não
estão vindo
amy aí o flamengo
eu to aqui porque o meu cargo está com
muito medo na boca ela estava claro que
não houve muito medo do meu carro
esperta a linha passa além do meu uma
mulher falar com um homem que
supostamente estava doente deixa quieta
terror e aí o lamê tudo mais calmo agora
cozinha lavar a luz só assim eu não
pareço aí eu acho que a petrobras cabeça
a limpa
eu tenho esse instrumento machida aí
possa em fotos sua força vou pegar fogo
a fuga aqui no bom caminho escreveu
antes de morrer lá atrás alguém morrer
lá atrás
aqui está a passar
[Música]
eu acho que a cantar uma canção
o tac o helicóptero pessoal me cobra
entrou na sala estatutos o ato tinha
muito medo real eu não sei explicar o
meu ou som eu comigo isso
[Música]
vamos fazer uma cuba 8 mais tão afiada e
ai não estou sozinha não
acabou a sua voz cantando ei pessoal nós
conseguimos resistir aqui ao unir pois
também estávamos dentro do manicômio de
uma casa ou numa prisão no ritual é não
sair mas eu estou muito medo pessoal se
vocês gostaram neste vídeo já sabem
quanto eu posso falar que o favorito se
quiserem ver mães que pelos vistos se
quiserem ver mais vídeos deste gênero
aqui no canal só com áudio assistir
áudio eu sei que na internet tem muitos
tons de por anormalidades reais funções
espiritistas rituais e também muita
coisa aí muita variedade a internet é um
mundo imenso de coisas novas é é é bom
você quiser ver mais tons versões vezes
é bom você quiser ouvir mais sons comigo
entre ti e já sabem deixou bastante
favorito e é isso fique bem está próxima
lula não só que o beijo dos noivos ela é
que alex frei dos apoios
[Música]